i don't know who set up this meeting but
you've got fleckess
who's he's a pretty big guy meeting up
with jerry nadler and jerry nadler is a
more
petite in the height department and
so it's just kind of a funny look to
begin with
flekas presents to congressman nadler
you know all the evidence about antifa
what does nadler have to say what are
they going to do about antifa
he denies it exists it is true there's
violence across the whole country do you
think this is from antifa
that's happening in portland right now
that's right that's that's a myth
that's being spread only in washington
d.c about antifa in portland
yes sir there's there's videos
everywhere online there's fires and
riots there's
they're throwing fireworks at uh federal
officers
dhs is there look online it gets crazy
mr nadler
it is crazy i love flekis's attitude
he's just saying it's like
because flekus looks a little bit like a
left winger you know he's got the beard
and everything
he's got he wears shorts a lot so left
wingers are more likely to talk to him
and then he comes up and he just spits
facts at them
and they run away as jerry nadler did
there
why does he deny this
as he denies this you can't deny the
everyone's seen the photos and i'm i'm
certain that people on capitol hill have
seen the photos and the videos
all over the country the democrats are
denying this because
antifa is the military wing of the
democratic party
that's it that's the only explanation
don't you think that you
if there were violence going on in the
streets
and this had no association with you and
you did not benefit from that violence
that you would denounce it or try to
stop it i mean you know the left always
says of the right
of the republicans that you know that
we've we've got these neo-nazis and
white supremacists who are really
pervasive and violent which is not true
they're like four of them in the entire
country
but every time you hear one of these
incidents of some
neo-nazis or something republicans
denounce it immediately
try to put a stop to it the left does
not do that with antifa
which is which is much more pervasive
and committing much more violence
why because antifa is the military wing
of the democratic party i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you